ご視聴ありがとうございました
一応、トヨタミの恋人、驚異的なツキの持ち主、千葉県出身
いいか、ハヤミは俺たちに2連勝しているが、まだ半チャン2回しか打ってない
長期戦に持ち込めば、絶対に俺たちが勝つ
でもよ、俺はあの女の月は本物だと思うけど
本物だ?
豊臣が天聖のスーパーズガンのように
あの女のバカ月も生まれついてるものなんじゃないかって気がするんだ
うん、だよな
弱気な奴らだ
テニスを餌に早見をホテルに誘い出し鉄丸に持ち込む
名付けて、蝶神暗号ホイホイ作戦
され行くわよ
され
もう全然打ち返せないじゃない
なんで豊臣までいるんだよ
仕方ねえだろうが
早見が豊臣くんが行くんなら行くって聞かねえんだから
おかわらず無知だね
岡本冬樹は無知棒前
いやー高田海子も結構バカだぞ
ごく
でも、なかなか難しいね。
最近の小学生は頭はいいんだな。
やっぱり、学級委員長がんばってるね。
お待たせ。
早かったね。
よし、じゃあさっそく始めるだよな。
僕も、僕も。
誰がおめえとやるなんて言った?
今日は俺たち、アキナちゃんと麻雀しに来ただよ。
早見にくっついてきたくせに、でっかい態度とるんじゃない!
そんな!
いいじゃない。みんな一緒にやりましょうよ。ね?
仕方ねえ。抜け番を決めるか。
E1引いたやつが最初。以下、2-1、3-1と順番に抜けていく。いいね。
2-1
3-1
E1
おめえ、相変わらず引きが弱いな。
リーチ!
相変わらず手が早いな
地位
現物
あーん、積もんない
食い取れ
数ピンか、食い取ってるかもしれんな
よーし、積もだけ4本7本
あーん、こんないい町だったのに
慎太郎がパーピンかキューピン積もればチーピンが出んのにな
やはり
俺が泣かなきゃスーピン一発積も
ハネマン引きやがってる
リーチ
なんだよこの女
三巡目でいきなりだか
年前なら単品三色だが
仕方ない
チーピンチーム
くそ!メンツができてるのに、泣いちまった!
一発ないんじゃ、しょうがない!
チーは?
無理やり食わなきゃ、ハヤミのツモだったか。
テンパった!
つぼれ!
ツモ!ゴッド!
高かったのに
なんじゃそりゃ
ペンチはまだ一発で積もってやがる
なんつー月の強さだ
落ち着け落ち着け
これであの女は二回羽目を逃したんだ
少しは月も落ちたはず
いつ
月が落ちるどころか二巡目のリーチかよ
しかも泣けなーい
泣けシン太郎
ああ、もう、先相撲しちゃったよ。
泣かさろ!ほっとけば必ず詰まるぞ!
よし!よし!お前、泣け!
なんだ?ほら、酷使やってんのに、どうやって泣くだよ!
ああ、少年、少年、少年、少年!
ルイチ初一発相撲!
見事だ!
よーし!今度は私の親ね!
お前ら!この親は死んでも泣かすぜ!
ダブルリーチ!
だ、誰か泣け!泣くんだ!
若い腕であんなもん泣けんかよ!
泣くんちゅなこれしかできねえ!
これ泣け!
これはどうだ!
おら、泣いてくる。
だめだ。
終わった。
展望車用意しとくべ。
6000円で足りるかな?
いいよ。
一発じゃ。
一発じゃ、ない。
ああ、そうだよな。
そんなにたびたび一発積もれるわけねえよな。
一時はどうなるかと思っちゃったね。
なんつーかこう、生きる気持ってもんが湧いてきちゃったね。
あっと、二発目ツモ。
ああ、ウラドラ三腕だ。
ダブリーツモ、メンホンチュン、三アンコウラウラ。
あら!独占ボールじゃ足りなかった!
なんだこれ!一発でチーワン積もってんじゃん!
えぇ、うそぉ!
一発積ものおヤバい逃して、三倍満積もり返すか、普通!
しかしこの女、最初四順目にリーチをかけて以来、三順目二順目ダブルリートを徐々に転廃が早くなってきてやがる。
ということは、次は?
やったー!最初から上がってる!つまんない!
てんてんほー!てんてんほー!
困ったら、どんな安い手であろうとも、先にてんぱってしまうしかない!
リーチ!安いぞ!振り込め!
拍手ってBのみだ!
おめぇ、うめぇこと言って、2着取るつもりだっぺ。
バカ!そんなこと言っとる場合かよ!
あ、出ちゃった。当たっちゃう。
惜しいけどね。
これで、ラスは誰かさんに決まったんでないでしょうか。
よくも。
ほら、2着取るぞ。
あ、ローン!
何?
ピンフー!三色ドラドラ!発戦だ!
おら!
お、おらから当たっただか?
おらから?
今まで、この三人のチームワークと友情は、
お互い点を取り合わないという大前提の上で成り立っていた。
今、その強い絆が断ち切られたのである。
なんとしても、延長するぞ!
ほら!先天訓論!
こいつ、人の最後の親を千点で蹴り上がって
ほらよ!
アタッ!
ねえ、今の渡し方、ジャンスのマナーに反するでないか?それ
そうかい、そりゃ悪かったな
悪かった、痛かっただよ
待て!お前ら仲間割れしてる場合じゃねえだろ
今はいかにして速水の月を落とすかが先決だろうが
ちっ、ま、慎太郎の言うとおりだ、しょうね
ふん
出た!ジュンちゃん三色ドランドラン!
ああ、あったね!
大下手!馬を一向に見ちゃねえや。
オラ!へんばこごとやんの!
何しやがんだ、てめぇ!
うるせぇ!おめぇ前から気に入らなかった、そのタバコ買いやがって!
- 何せよ!- 何で食べるぞ!
- 何やるか!- 痛って!
くっから!
なかっ!次はおめえの抜け番だ!さっさと、同感かい!
よるさねー!
今のこいつらだったら、ひょっとして勝てるかも。
いや、絶対に勝てる!次のハンチャン、必ず三着を取ってみせる!
頑張って、トヨタミック!
織田たちによる恐るべき提灯暗光ホイホイ作戦は
秋名の馬鹿好きの前にもろくも崩れ去った
しかし戦いはまだ終わっていない
最大のつかんぽ豊臣の間の手が忍び寄ろうとしていることを
秋名は知らなかった
よーし
つまんねーの
今度は俺の抜け番かよ
あら
あのいつも冷静なアケチが鼻からカップ麺を吹き出した
それほどまでにすごいハイパイが早めに入っているというのか
ここは一気に地位だ
三色ドライチー2、3点
あら、いい泣き
C
よし、テンパイだ
キレイ
サブローピン少数子、テンパイ
あのオシャレなアケチが鼻からエビまで出して呆然としている
テンパッタか
やったー!30名高めピーク出敗!絶好調!
3ピン!
あ、出ちゃった
当たれないわ
せっかく燃えてるトヨタミ君を
いきなりラス、ドンケツ、ドベビリ再開に決定させてしまうなんて
平気、サブローピンぐらいすぐ積もれるわ
てらー!
きったね!
何かある、絶対何かある
ウーピンか
ジャンソーをギャンピンと泣かせてあの捨て牌だ
ウーピンは通るな
これよ
な、なんだこの寒気は
案外あれでピンズのチン打つとか
そうだ、そうに違いない
なんて勘のいい奴だ
じゃあ、つも切り
そう数字だけ48,000からいきなり4倍役満の192,000点
さっきの見逃してこれ当たっちゃう余計試算よね
そんなやつなんか構うことはねえ
当たっちゃう当たっちゃう
やっぱり積もっちゃう
どうしよう
おー!
うぴん通ったのかよ!
あ!慎太郎君の手の中にまだシロが!
さっき一枚切ってるってことは、次で出る。
よっ、つもぎり!
なんてつかんぽなの、この子は。
でも、山越しで次、慎太郎くんのシロで当たれるから、見逃してあげるね。
さあ、出せ、シロ。
出たー!バカの!
ダメ
見逃してねお願い
豊臣くん
仕方ねえな
わー!やさしい!豊臣くん大好き!
にゃーんちってー!
ビーフ飲み!
麻雀は非常だぜ、ベイビー
と、豊臣くんのバカー!
ああ、豊臣、おめえひでえやつ
アキナちゃんば、なっかしみやんの。
なにが、たかだかせんてんで、ばっかしゃらんの?
自分は絶対振らないって、うぬぼれてんじゃないの?
おやとび、おべえな。
明智、まだ鼻から麺が出てるよ。
アキナちゃんはな。
明智君、もういいわ。ごめんなさい。
さあ、続けましょ。
ちぇ、女ってやつは、いちいちめんどくさいぜ。
おら!
ロン!ダンヤオ、イーペイコ、ドラドラ!
早ぇなぁ!まだ6巡目だぜ!
とこは、何度も会ったら少しは喜べよな!
ロン!ピンク3色、ドラ1!
ハイテイ、ドラドラ!
うぎゃー!
ピーチ!メンホン!ナン!サンアンコ!
本郎!小三軒!
徹底的に豊臣一人をマークしている。
復讐法。これは復讐なんだ!
おめえが振ってばっかりっからオラが一個に上がれねーべよ、このピョガトリコ!
このままじゃこのままだ!
たとえ焼け石に水でも、オーラス多少なりとも取り返さなくっちゃ!
ポン!
チー!
裸探偵!
風邪ひかねえように気ぃつけろって。
ほんじゃ、オープンリーチすっぺ。
リーチ!
リャンウーピン町のリーチだっぺ。
なんだそれ。
リャンピン3枚にウーピン3枚、場に出てんじゃん。
あと2枚、トヨトミがつかむべよ。
えへへ、そんなの誰かが使ってるよ。
つかみそうな気がする。
スーパーズガー
やろうほんとにつかんだみたいだぜ
てのうちからドラがでてきたんべ
おっとこいつはしょんぱいだ
ぽん
おらつも
あらもう
ぽん
たのむルーピンつかむらよ
ほい
ぽん
アキナ
まさか
どうしたの?
あ、あきなちゃん
なーに?
さっきは先天で蹴ったりしてごめんね
僕が悪かったんだ、反省してるよ
やだそんなこと、私もう全、全気にしてなんかないのよ
いいから早く切って
あれは気にしてるって顔だぜ
それも超恨んでるって顔だ
ちゃおー
ローン!
大数寺ツーイーソー!
三大ヤクマン!
ギャンピン聞いときゃただのヤクマンだったのに、バカなやつだべ!
はぁー!
トヨトミが入って、俺たちなんとかチャラだな!
とっても面白かったわ!また、みんなでやりましょうね!
おぉー!
何喜んでるの、トヨトミ君?
え?
あなたも一緒にとは誰も言っていないわよ。
えぇ!?
豊臣の奴がいない場合、負けは俺たちがかぶるってことに?
うん、だな
あの、はやみくん、そんなこと言わずに豊臣くんも入れてあげたら?
いいのよ!さあ、みんな行きましょ!
あの、僕は?
一人で負けたんだから、罰として歩いて帰りなさい!
わしよー!
アキナちゃーん
ついにアキナにも愛想をつかされてしまったトヨトミ
この晩秋に降り注ぐ日雨は
彼の冷え切った心から流れ出る涙なのでありましょうか
止めてくれるなおっかさん
男トヨトミどこへ行く
この次はあの謎のたらこ唇男ババさんと
もう一人謎の関西青年の登場です
それから温泉旅行もあります
次回スーパーズガン
大阪からの物体X
湯渡りズガン
きっと見てね
眠っちゃいや
スカン スカン スカン
It's time for the voice of the thunder
The international star of stars
ミナミ・ハロー
セクが騒ぐな 慌てるな
愛を掴めば 天国ロマンの夢が湧く
運動天空と理想が来る
飛べてくるんだ 対面者
スカンと 行かねばならぬのだ
リティバックビーフリーツ
ひもちゃかみちゃばじゃん仲間
勝負かけたら情けもよものがないうち
君はアゲマンの主席じゃないか
僕とワンガンズフォローよ
スカンと幸せスカボード
スーパースター
やりでやりのまんまく心 呼んでやりながら
ここは三面町どころ 行くなカミキャン 徳島そこの石が花
相撲にも負けんのにやりづいて 勝って飲み干すビールがうまい
スカット オタカワイドチガケ
ご視聴ありがとうございました